[Musique]
les charcuterie de volaille au cul près
de la moitié du marché des viandes
froides au canada si vous regardez
passant des 25 dernières années les
viandes rouges sont en décroissance par
capita alors que le poulet rendu au
canada la viande la plus populaire par
capita depuis quelques temps on remarque
changement d'attitude de l'industrie qui
veut s'adapter aux demandes des
consommateurs
on voit que les entreprises font de
grands efforts on voit les produits qui
ont aussi peu que cet ingrédient les
ingrédients facilement d'une table qu'on
est chez nous à la maison dans l'armoire
ce qu'on nous demande stopper la même
chose que dans la charcuterie en général
il ya un effort pour essayer de
simplifier nos listes d'ingrédients il
ya un effort pour essayer de garder
conservé par contre le bon goût et la
praticité les raisons premières pourquoi
des gens mangent des charcuteries ce
parce qu'ils trouvent que ça goûte bon
pique c'est facile c'est simple ça coûte
pas trop cher
une des raisons qui motivent l'industrie
à modifier les listes d'ingrédients
c'est la déclaration de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé à l'effet que les
nitrites dans les charcuteries sont
potentiellement cancérigènes le plus
important rôle du nitrite dans les
charcuteries était de préserver donc
limiter la multiplication bactérienne à
cela on ajoute et la coloration du
charbon par exemple et une certaine
sarah rossi le clic particulière aux
charcuteries qui est issu des nitrites
donc les nitrites combinée à une
protéine et combiné aussi un traitement
thermique ont été démontés comme étant
cancérigènes dans l'organisme dans le
code de nos produits de volaille on a
retiré les nitrites complètement pas
donné trip chimiques ni de nitrites
provenant de l'extrait de celui dans
notre corps on a décidé de les retirer
et de garder le goût naturel du pied de
l'âne dans ce cas là on utilise du
vinaigre
ces propriétés
antimicrobienne remplacent les unités
c'est pas tout à fait le simple vinaigre
il est un peu transformé nos
fournisseurs d'ingrédients qui nous
accompagnent le vent mais eux ils sont l
identifier les molécules qui pouvait
être fonctionnel pour aller contrer la
croissance microbienne
on voit des jeunes et qu'on voit de jus
de citron concentriques qui font ce
travail là et on veut aussi maintenant
des extraits donc extraits de levure
extraits des pistes des extraits de
fruits qui ont aussi le rôle antioxydant
et le rôle de d'amener un peu de savoir
chose que limited faisait aussi en
charcuterie on ne peut se passer de
sodium c'est un élément essentiel dans
le processus de fabrication
encore là on perçoit un effort de
réduction autrefois on msa des
productivités salines de plus en plus
les consommateurs trouvent que les
produits sont trop salée le fait
d'enlever les retards manque de sodium
line trop de sodium les phosphates de
sodium
on a réduit un pull l'apport en sodium
mais n'aurait sans même le crb fait qu
on veut que ça soit mouture puis ont vu
que l'extraction des protéines s'efface
quand même pied les c'est la haine aussi
pour la durée de vie même si notre corps
a besoin sodium
il reste que l'accumulation dans une
journée peut être problématique sans
regarde un peu les produits qu'on ici
trois tranches et très peu qui peuvent
mettre une fois et demie la cance et
donc ont donc déjà quand même être 700
mg de sodium du père mais la mayonnaise
lamentable peu importe les candidats
dans tout ça ça fait grimper rapidement
la quantité de sodium comme un genre
lorsqu'on choisit une charcuterie le
pourcentage de protéines de viande est
un bon indicateur du degré de
transformation du produit par exemple
une poitrine de d'un cru qu'on tient au
départ entre 23 et 24 % de protéines de
viande
la plupart des produits de charcuterie
évidemment à un taux plus bas qu 23
parce qu'on ajoute des ingrédients on
rajoute los angeles elle qui on a besoin
de l'eau parce qu'il faut se mobiliser
tous ces ingrédients là le pourcentage
de protéines nous indique le pourcentage
qui est reste dans le produit
une fois les ingrédients de la nation à
utiliser le minimum requis pour des
charcuteries et de 12% de la chose
intéressante à travers des produits
charcuterie la législation oblige toutes
les industries à mettre directement sur
l'emballage pourcentage de 3 tient donc
c'est beaucoup plus facile de pouvoir
comparer les produits en verseau
voyons maintenant quels sont les
produits les plus intéressants de notre
échantillonnage sur près de 40 18 ont
plus de 20 % de protéines de viande
11 ne contiennent aucun nitrites parmi
ceux-ci 4 au moins 2 400 mg de sodium
par portion de 50 5 g menu bleu poitrine
de dinde rôtie au four sensation
poitrine de dinde cuite rustique et
poitrine de dinde cuite aux herbes de
provence est la moins chère du lot la
poitrine de dan tranché mon marché
fraîcheur vous avez donc le choix parmi
beaucoup de produits qui démontre les
efforts déployés par l'industrie pour se
rapprocher des demandes des
consommateurs et simplifier leurs façons
de faire mais il faut quand même garder
l'oeil ouvert
ce qu'on nous va c'est la naturalité
faut faire attention parce que le terme
nature naturel n'est pas réglementée
d'aucune façon sucre de canne sa fille
naturelle l'utilisation des termes le ca
reste du sucre blaquart on remarque
qu'une transition du consommateur vers
les faits autant que possible les deux
allégations qu'on a retenu ces deux
faits la première c'est sans ajout
d'ingrédients artificiels la deuxième
c'est excellente source de protéines
on applaudit meilleur monopoly plus sain
où on ne m'en donner des faits donc le
consommateur devient plus exigeant
j'étais gay un mélange d'exigence
cynique et informer c'est sûr que
l'industrie nous offre une gamme qui est
infini de produits on le voit bien mais
tout est dans la variété on mais
possédant nolin déjà tous les jours si
c'est possible on varie la frottée ont
fait maison xi s'est passé aussi donc on
peut comparer par exemple avec une
poitrine de poulet ou un poulet condé
zoss nous mêmes à la maison on est loin
d' on est loin des ingrédients qui ont
été ajoutés on ne la possibilité
d'aromatiser nous-mêmes de salé nous
manque donc ça fait
mais une différence au niveau de la
valeur nutritive et des ingrédients
qu'ont les gens le travail lundi
[Musique]